musicien s'appelle bliss qui nous dit
qui veut dire personne intime c'est le
tout nouveau rendez vous hebdomadaire
sur la très populaire chaîne de
télévision d'état reussir avec l'aide
d'un avocat de psychologues les invités
et les animateurs dont margarita gratte
show va débattre du sort des couples en
difficulté
la fidélité et la jalousie sont des
thèmes populaires et même si l'émission
peut faire dans le spectacle elle est la
seule et surtout la première qui se
consacre principalement à la violence
conjugale en russie parmi les invités
lors de la grande première il y avait
une jeune femme vera venu demander de
l'aide
parce que son mari l'a terrorisée que la
police refuse de les big hit i wanna be
geek sauve toi tout de suite en courant
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard lui a
conseillé cette grand mère dont la fille
a été assassinée à coups de couteau par
son conjoint
alors que leur fils dormait dans la
pièce à côté une histoire d'horreur qui
a ébranlé tout le plateau aux recherches
kravis et la coanimatrice margarita
ghjuvan ne peut retenir ses larmes car
chaque histoire la replonge dans la
sienne ou jour en 2017 ou son propre
mari lui a tranché les mains avec une
hache
malgré de nombreux appels à l'aide qui
ont été ignorées heures version mono
espérons une telle émission aurait été
impensable en russie il ya quelques
années dit l'avocat alexandre daube
robin ski qui conseille les victimes sur
le plateau le cas de marée est un jouet
90e
grand rôle dans le dans notre société
les gens commencent à réfléchir un peu
différemment réfléchir au fléau qu'est
la violence conjugale en russie surtout
depuis que le gouvernement l'a
décriminalisée en 2010 est qu'en
l'absence de lois et de protection les
femmes comme margarita sont laissées à
elles mêmes
impuissante face à leurs agresseurs
parce qu'on voit cette dame on voit les
moments de cette c'est visible ses
volets pour les gens
maria rita a changé depuis que nous
l'avons rencontré il ya un an et demi
elle s'est remariée ses enfants vont
bien
son courage et sa résilience on devenu
une source d'inspiration en arriver là
et directrice de l'organisme non à la
violence ou les femmes peuvent venir se
confier à moscou en toute sécurité et
obtenir de l'aide juridique au moins une
centaine viennent chaque mois diana la
parole se libère un projet de loi qui
prévoyait des mesures de prévention
comme des ordres de protection de la
cour a été abandonné par la douma l'an
dernier et ce à la demande de la très
puissante église orthodoxe
l'organisme non à la violence continue
de militer auprès des élus et son action
politique qui constamment dans la mire
les autorités le gouvernement le même
placé sur la liste des agents étrangers
en janvier dernier l'émission n'est pas
parfaite dit l'avocat alexandre do
brodinski mais c'est un début c'est mon
devoir de
frappé d'un rapport de main et de dire
écoutez il est temps de changer les
joints et les temps d'être plus sévère
changer de nom c'est beaucoup plus
difficile que changer les lois ici
surtout notre but du marguerite à
épuiser émotive entre deux
enregistrements
l'essentiel c'est que peu à peu en
russie nous ne nous plions plus ainsi